Squeezie : AHHH j'ai pas de jeu pour aujourd'hui putain la page blanche, la page blanche !
Cyprien  : Eh tu veux une mise à jour ?
Squeezie : Eh frère t'as un bon produit pour moi ?
Cyprien : Ouais t’inquiète.
Squeezie : Ça va faire des vues ou pas ? Ça va faire des vues ?
Cyprien : Une mise a jour d'un jeu idéal !
Squeezie : Eh frère donne donne, eh frère frère donne DONNE !!!!!!!
Cyprien : ATTENTION Y'A LES FLICS  Y'A LES FLICS !!!!!!
Squeezie : Donne le Zedou ! casse-toi !
Cyprien : Bonjour !
Squeezie : Bonjour !
On est sur Touch ID ou saisie du code. Comment ça va ?
Cyprien : On est sur la mise à jour du "Nope Quizz".
Squeezie : Nope Quizz que vous avez tous torché ne faites pas semblant...
Cyprien : C'est aujourd'hui tu peux la télécharger gratuitement, c'est une mise à jour.
Squeezie : C'est une mise à jour et nous n'allons pas faire toute la mise à jour, nous allons va faire la moitié nous allons faire 10 questions c'est ça ?
Cyprien :On va faire 10 questions.
Squeezie : ... sur 20.
(Hummm) c'est mes mails.
Squeezie : Nous allons faire une vidéo sur tes mails, c'est intéressant.
Ubisoft,  proposition d' "OPSP".Cyprien ?
Cyprien : Alors non j'ai dû tomber dans tes mails alors...
*rires*
Cyprien : Voici la mise à jour du" Nope Quizz";
Squeezie : Merci.
Merci, ça me fait très plaisir!
J'ai hésité à faire cette vidéo en échange de ton diamond bouton... Mais il est à ton bureau :'(
Cyprien : Huh.... Je viendrais la prochaine fois parce qu'il y a encore une autre mise a jour
Squeezie :NAN! Mais voila on reconnait les frères on reconnait les pas frères c'est pas grave .
La gamerie... Qui est le nom de ton studio de jeux vidéos !
Cyprien : EXACTEMENT!!!  On est parfaitement 2
Squeezie : Ah bah ça commence avec ... Une PUB !
BAH BRAVO!!!!
NON MAIS!!! On reconnait les vrais on reconnait les faux c'est pas grave
Cyprien : C'est.... Le jeu est gratuit  ... Hein... donc
Squeezie : Bah oui ce jeu a l'air bien  donc on va peut-être faire la vidéo là-dessus finalement
( Rires de Squeezie et de Cyprien ! )
Squeezie : Allez !
Avec un icône de slip pour ces  nouvelles questions !
Mouais !
Présentateur du Nope Quizz  : Tu es revenu pour souffrir encore plus ? Génial!
Tu as déjà eu 114 Nope. T'es vraiment nul!
Squeezie : Ah bah c'est toi!
Cyprien :Oui c'est le cumul de (Cyprien rigole)
Squeezie : 114 nopes a ton propre jeu ...  C'est chaud quand même !
Cyprien : Je suis très nul je suis vraiment très très nul .
C'EST PARTI !
Squeezie : C'est parti !
Cyprien : 61 à 70
Squeezie : Je.... J'appuie sur le slip
Présentateur du Nope Quizz : Quelle personnalité n'a jamais fait de pub pour whisky ?
Squeezie : EUH mais..... attends en fait j'avais dans la tête Whiskas  mais ça n'a rien a voir ...
Quelle personnalité n'a jamais fait de pub pour DU whisky ?
David Beckham
Bill Murray
Jude Law
Bruce Willis
( Squeezie est choqué)
Cyprien :  Il y en a 3 qui ont fait des pub pour du whisky .
Squeezie :  Il y en a 3 qui ont fait des pub pour du whisky .
Je dirais franchement mec ,  David Beckham c'est un sportif  , un peu "Healthy" tout ça ...
Cyprien : Ah healthy ... ( Squeezie répète ce que dit Cyprien )
Squeezie : Eh bah voila parfait !
Pas très sportif finalement... hein !
Bruce Willis , je le vois bien faire une pub pour du whisky ... Je le vois bien avec un verre de whisky à la main .
Et vu que je le vois bien avec un verre de whisky à la main , c'est que c'est lui qui en a pas fait !
ET VOILAAA !
Cyprien : OUAAAAH !
Squeezie : La contre théorie ! Qu'est ce tu vas faire ? Ah ... Quel talent !
Cyprien : Eh oui , il y a beaucoup de stars d'Hollywood qui ont fait des pubs pour du whisky !
Squeezie : Ouais c'est ouf ... En France c'est pas un truc qui se fait , tu vois ...
Cyprien : Bah en fait on a déjà Gérard Depardieu qui boit tout le whisky , nous on fait l'inverse !
Rires de Squeezie
Squeezie : Nan toi tu m'as dis , par contre panaché ça te brancherait un peu ... ( Référence à la vidéo : Expert en séduction )
Présentateur : Bruce Willis est bien la seule personnalité  à ne pas avoir fait de publicité pour du whisky. Il en a fait pour de la vodka .
Squeezie : Ah oui bon , finalement il est ...
Cyprien : Rires
Oui c'est vrai , il a trouvé un truc à côté ...
Squeezie : Ouais un truc annexe ...
Présentateur : Trouve le vrai logo USB .
Squeezie : Oh bataaaaaard ...
Cyprien : Ouais maitenant je le connais ...
Squeezie : Pour le coup j'aimerais bien que ce soit celui en bas à droite pour le coup ...
Rires de Cyprien
Squeezie : Il te met le smile dès que tu branches un port USB , il te met le smile
Euuh attends ... J'crois que c'est .. Attends ...
Cyprien : Est ce que vous savez , vous , derrière votre écran ? Oui je parle comme un vieux ...
Squeezie : C'est soit celui là , soit celui là ... Celui où le trait du milieu , il y a une flèche au bout déjà ... C'est sûr !
Euuuuuuh ... Je dirais que c'est lui !
( Exclamations de Squeezie et Cyprien )
Squeezie : What a No-Life ( Même celle qui a fait les sous-titres n'a pas compris )
Cyprien : P*tain mais j'hallucine ...
Squeezie : What a No-Life ...
Cyprien : J'suis vraiment , euuuh ...
Présentateur : Ah , je vois que tu es un vrai geek ! Est ce que tu peux regarder mon ordinateur ? Il ne s'allume plus ...
Squeezie : Non !
Tu appelleras l'assistance pour computer !
(Rires de Cyprien)
Présentateur : Lesquelles de ces villes d'Islande n'existent pas ?
Squeezie : Oh j'ai envie d'aller en Islande , du coup !
Cyprien : Bah ça va te faire voyager !
Squeezie : Ouai, bah ouai, tout à fait
Bjork-en-Provence
*rire*
On va pas se mytho (mentir)
Poitier
Chand-Mé ( Méchant )
On est pas mal pour l'instant
franchement euh... j'suis impressionné...
C'est vrai ?
Ah le coup du logo USB, j' me suis dis putain
on parle à un geek là
en fait j'ai regardé...
Nan c'est faux c'est faux
OH MON DIEU mais qu'est ce qui nous arrive
est ce que les gens arriveront à faire un meilleur score que moi ?
Nan mais vraiment mec
on se le demande
( Lit ce qui est écrit )
tu les as tous vus ?
nan
j'en ai vu qu'un
bah avatar nan
en vrai avatar c'est ça aussi
c'est un homme blanc qui découvre un nouveau monde, les hommes bleus,
qui se lie d'amitié avec eux
Mais ses confrères ils veulent démonter les... les hommes bleus
oui c'est... c'est le pitch du film
ah il y en a plusieurs ok d'accord
Ah putain je croyais que il n'y en avait qu'un
"Danse avec les loups" , c'est un mec qui découvre un loup, il se fait pote avec lui,
et ses potes veulent buter (tuer) les loups
peut-être, j'sais pas.
C'est très bizarre de... parler d'un film que t'as pas vu
Alors c'est l'histoire...
Mais je connais pas.
D'un loup
Ouais, ... Ouais, ... Non c'est tous ?
Comme ça je me prends la tête pour euh, pour rien ?
Ah mais t'es une grosse sal*pe, mon gars
Depuis toute à l'heure je, je me prends la tête
et t'es là tu me fais : ouais attends c'est ça, ouais ok, il est à fond
( Lit ce qui est écrit )
Squeezie : Mec, la moitié des trucs c'est ça quoi, c'est vrai hein !
Euuuuuhm...
Humm...
Je...
*Surpris*
*Squeezie Rigole tandis que Cyprien se lamente à cause que squeezie à REKT son jeu :c*
Cet homme est surhumain
C'est incroyable
Oh p*tain, ça j'suis toujours très très nul
Relie ces animaux dangereux à leur territoire
Oh là j'suis, là j'suis mort
J'ai eu trop de chatte c'est mort là
Alors pour le coup, je peux te donner un indice
Ils sont tous presque très très mortels
Sauf le crocodile marin
La veuve noire à dos rouge, si le dos était bleu, tu vois, ça passe
Cyprien : Ah oui, le modèle bleu
On est sur un dos rouge
Veuve noire à dos rouge, je dirais que c'est un truc genre d'Amérique du Sud ça
Jeu: NOPE
Bah voilà c'est rapide
Je dirais c'est un truc d'Afrique centrale ça
Oh noooon
En fait t'as eu trop de chatte donc maintenant tu perds
Donc on avait dit du coup : ça doit être Australie cette merde
Ouais c'est ça
P*taiiiiiiin mais mec j'aurais dû me douter
Serpent taïpan
Alors le serpent taïpan ça fait vachement Chine
Bah voilà merci
Alors taïpan ça fait vachement Afrique centrale je trouve
Nan mais je sais
Taïpan ça fait quand même vachement Amérique du sud
Oh t'es une p*te
Oh t'es... Oh t'es... T'es tellement
Oh le b*tard il a fait le piège tu peux en relier deux à un seul, oh p*taiiiin
La blague c'est qu'ils viennent tous d'Australie, voilàààà ok j'en étais sûr
C'est le pays où il y a le plus d'insectes et d'animaux chelous
*lit le texte sur l'écran*
Mec c'est tellement ça
J'ai trop envie d'y aller, mais c'est vraiment le truc qui me bloque c'est ça en fait
C'est le fait que la faune et la flore...
Cyprien : C'est pas le fait que ce soit extrêmement loin ?
Tu peux être mangé par une plante quoi là-bas tu vois, c'est chaud quoi !
Quel ingrédient ne figure pas dans la recette du Coca-Cola ?
Sulfite d'ammonium, ça c'est un truc qui te ronge euuh
Alors pour tous ceux qui sont un peu fans de physique-chimie n'est-ce pas
Benzoate de sodium... Chlorure de potassium, c'est ça non ? Bah oui
Chlorure de potassium !
Ouais parce que je suis un peu chimiste hein !
Cyprien : "Je suis un peu chimiste !"
*lis le texte sur l'écran*
Ahhh bon on n'est pas loin quand même
C'est vraiment le truc, l'étal (pas sûre de l'écriture de ce mot...) tu sais euhm...
*silence*
Quand y'a pas... Voilà.
Bah merci pour cette anecdote.
69 ! La question 69, attention
Cyprien : Ouuuh attention
"Manger 5 000 fruits et légumes par jour" Bah je prends mec c'est... Je pense c'est pas ça !
T'as regardé les effets que ça peut avoir sur le corps ?
Euuuh, c'est...Tu meurs.
"Révéler un secret de la NSA" ou "Un pique-nique à Fukushima"
Bah logiquement c'est le pique-nique à Fukushima mais est-ce que la vanne c'est pas Australie qui est le plus...
Ah non c'est bon, c'est bien Fukushima !
"Révéler un secret de la NSA" oh oui, et vivre en Australie.
Moi j'aurais quand même mis "Vivre en Australie" avant tout...
Espèce d'enfoiré j'en étais sûr...
Oh bâtaaaaard j'en étais tellement sûr, noooon !!
Attends mais c'est méga long !
Navré, navré pour cette question...
Oh oui, oh putain mais mec là...
Le kapla mon gars, t'as transpercé un mec de l'autre coté de la tour t'as même pas fait gaffe quoi
Oh ! Le cadeau... Attention, qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir ?
C'est le Golden, c'est le Golden... C'est le Diamond Button
Bah non, c'est mieux que le Diamond Button
C'est des super vacances au soleil ! C'est vrai, je vais avoir des vacances au soleil Cyprien ?
Allez on veut la suite !
Cyprien : Euh non non, hop hop hop !
Faut le mériter !
C'est pour vous les internautes la suite ! Voilà c'est à télécharger gra... Je fais un petit peu la promo ?
C'est à télécharger gratuitement...
Squeezie : Attention, attention, attention, top !
Cyprien : Oui bonjour, c'est un jeu gratuit / Squeezie : 10, 9, 8...
Cyprien : C'est disponible sur Android et iOS et euh c'est très plaisant / Squeezie : 6, 4, 2...
Cyprien : Et il reste plein de trucs à faire ! / Squeezie : 0 ! C'est fini !
Et il va y avoir des mises à jour très bientôt ! Oh t'as triché là, j'ai entendu !
Cyprien : Il va y avoir une prochaine mise à jour avec des trucs de ouf qui vont arriver, ça on le garde sous le coude
Squeezie : Eh mais toi t'es ambidextre quoi, le gars il arrive à faire son discours tout en entendant si je joue ou pas
Eh le mec il est trop fort !
*petit silence*
Squeezie : C'est tout...
Eh bah les amis n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu !
N'hésitez pas à faire ces questions-là et à faire les 10 suivantes, voilà
Cyprien : Ou si vous avez jamais joué au jeu, c'est gratuit euh... / Squeezie : À tout faire !
Squeezie : À tout refaire, toutes les questions sont dispo et puis on retrouve pour une prochaine
Squeezie : Merci Cyprien pour cette mise à jour en avant-première / Cyprien : Merci à toi, j'espère que ça t'a plu
J'ai beaucoup ri, j'ai beaucoup aimé - et j'ai encore moins envie d'aller en Australie, ouais j'adore
Cyprien : Haha "J'ai plus envie d'aller en Australie"
Et il nous reste encore du très lourd aussi sur les questions qu'on n'a pas encore fait
Et puis des prochaines mises à jour
Squeezie : Y'aura encore une mise à jour ?
Cyprien : Je veux pas spoiler, parce que pour l'instant on a les modes avec les niveaux tu vois
Squeezie : Ouais / Cyprien : Il va y avoir un nouveau mode de jeu
Un nouveau mode de jeu ? Genre comme Rocket League, ils sont passés du foot au basket dans Rocket League t'as vu
Eh ben voilà c'est une comparaison de merde
Eh ben voilà, à bientôt les amis, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien ciao tout le monde !
Cyprien : Peace ! :D